CHRIS ROONEY AND JOHN
TOEWS, A DRIVE.
SQUEEZED BETWEEN THE PADS OF
POINTS IN ONLY STAMKOS GROUP WA
JUST ON.DRAW, AND
THE ON CLEANLY BACK TO ERIK  BA,
AND JOHHEDMAN, BUT THEY
COULDN'T CLEAR IT, AND THEN  RO.
NOWHERE TO GO.
TURN IT OVER QUICKLY.
PERRY PERRY.
COUNTERBY NICHUSHKIN.
HAS A MAN JUST ONCOMING WITH
N.
WRISTER RIGHT ON BY MAE
FOREHAND, AND A NIFTY HIGH ATTE
GLOVE.
TIMER.IME IT'S BRANDON HAGEL
STEERED ASIDE.
GOOD TIME IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
THEY H HDEAD.
HERE'S MacKINNON WAVING.
TRIED TOTO
DELAYED PENALTY HERE AGAINST
TAMPA BAY.
KADRI'S SHOT!
DIDN'T HAVE MUCH ON
>> Ray: KADRI HAS A SHOT THAT
DEFLECTS UP OVER
RANTANEN.
MAKAR THOUGHT ABOUT A ONE TIMER.
ROOM
RUSH.
HAS HELP.
PUT IT RIGHT
HAS A TRAILER IN COMPHE
ACCIDENT.
AND TAMPA BAY LEADS, 1-0.
LOOKED LIKE A FAIRLY HIS GLOVE.
MY BAD. OUT.
WINDS KADRI.
STILL FREE.
AND IT POPS IN THE AIR OVER THE
OWN END.
THEY'VE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
KEEPING I I
AND NICHUSHKIN, WHO WAS REALLY
QUIET IN GAMES THREE AND FOUR IS
ON THE SPOT.
THE BUGAIN, 2-1.
HE CAN'T GET IN THE PUCK LANE AS
IT GOES JUST OVER HIS LEG
THROUGH THE SCREEN OF21.
DIDN'T THINK THIS SITUATIONHE 2
PERIOD.
CALE MAKAR, THROUGH THE DE THE D
EMILY KAPLAN.
AND THE THIRD PERIOD UNDER WAY
AS THE FACE-OFF WAS WON BY IN A.
CALE MAKAR WILL GET IN THE THIR.
SERGACHEV WRISTS ONE.
IT HIT
ANOTHER HUGE GOAL INSIDE OF